welcome back to the course
um
in this series of sessions we're going
to be talking about deep learning this
is one of the new chapters in the second
edition of introduction to statistical
learning deep learning is a new name for
neural networks which became popular in
the 1980s there were lots of successes
hype and and great conferences that's
where the start of the europe's sequence
were and the snowbird sequence
and rob you and i went
we were regular attendees of those
conferences yeah from about 85 to
into the 90s yeah initially one of the
attractions apart from all the really
interesting work was they were held in
ski resorts so it was an opportunity to
both learn interesting new stuff and get
some skiing in then along came support
vector machines random forest and
boosting which you've learnt about in
this course or about to learn about
and the neural networks took a bit of a
back seat
they re-emerged around 2010 with a new
name deep learning
and by the 2020s they became very
dominant and successful
and they used all over the place now
so part of the success
was due to the vast improvements in
computing power
much bigger training sets and software
the main software platforms are
tensorflow which is a google
software and pytorch which comes from
facebook
but much of the credit goes to three
pioneers
and their students there's young lacoon
jeffrey hinton and yoshio banjo who
received the 2019 acm turin award for
their work in in neural networks and
you'll find on the website for the
course we do it trevor and i have an
interview with jeff hinton
talking about the history of neural
networks and
any development since the 80s yes and
and we've known these three gentlemen
pretty much for their whole uh careers
um
young lacoon was at um bell labs um in
the in the 80s and 90s and i was there
at the same time joshua benjo was a
frequent visitor
and
and rob worked with
jeff hinton at university of toronto
okay so let's get started we'll start
off with a really simple single layer
neural network sometimes called a feed
forward
neural network
and neural networks are often displayed
using what's known as network diagrams
and here we see such a network diagram
in the orange we've got the input layer
here in this example we've got four
variables
and then we have what's known as a
hidden layer
and there's five units in the hidden
layer here and then there's the output
layer
and the way you think of the hidden
layer is you think of them as
transformations of the inputs
the a stand for activations and we'll
get into the the detailed notation in a
moment so where's the observed data is
it all observed
um rob this is observed the x's are
observed
and the output y is observed
it's a response
but the a's aren't observing i actually
knew the answer but you knew there no i
thought it'd be good to explain
and these these activations are computed
in fact in this equation over here
they named the h k of x so the k
activation is a transformation of the
inputs x
and these little arrows indicate
linear combinations of these x's that
feed into each of these hidden units
and here h k of x is expanded
as
a function which is going to be a
nonlinear function of a linear
combination of the inputs
and each of those linear combinations is
different so the linear combination
feeding into a1 is different to the one
feeding into a2 so what you can think of
is these are transformations that are
learned
when you train the network these
transformations are learned on the fly
so let's look in a little bit more
detail
the ak these are the activations as i
said they're h k of x and we can think
of it as a non-linear transformation of
a linear function
and they called again activations in the
hidden layer
now these non-linear functions there's a
choice and they called activation
functions
and two that are popular the sigmoid and
the rectified linear
so in the early neural networks the
sigmoids were popular so you can see
it's a nonlinear function
it takes sort of a standardized range
look z is running from minus four to
four and it maps it to the interval zero
one
in like a smooth transformation it's
actually the same transformation that's
used in logistic regression
the black one is the one that's more
popular today
it's called a relu
function which stands for rectified
linear unit
and look what it does it's it's zero up
to
if if z
is less than or equal to zero it returns
zero and after zero it returns a non and
it returns a linear function
so it basically truncates at zero
and
since there's an intercept in each of
these
transformations what zero on the z scale
you know can move around because of that
intercept
so why non-linear
well if they weren't non-linear for
example if the activation function was
linear
then the whole network would just be a
linear model
because then you would have
linear transformations of
linear variables become you know you
just get one big linear model
so if you didn't do nonlinear
activations it would just be a big
linear model
and so again the activations are the
like derived features
that we learn when we train the model
and then with all that in place you fit
the model by minimizing
say for for regression and squared error
loss you just minimize the sum of
squares like you would for regression
but
this f
right so f was at the
the end of the pipeline here f
encompasses a lot of parameters right
there's a parameters going from the
hidden layer
to the output layer and there's the
parameters going from the inputs to the
all the hidden units so there's a lot of
parameters
and you'll see
that's something that characterizes
neural networks there can be lots of
parameters
so
let's get on to a more serious example
so this is the amnest digit data
these digit data this is like a test
bench for neural networks in fact i
would say neural networks really started
with handwritten digit classification
so you can see that these handwritten
digits
have been scanned in
right they've been they've been written
with a pen or pencil typically taken
from envelopes and they've been scanned
in and they've been normalized in this
case to 28 by 28 grayscale images
what that means is yeah we've blown up
some three of the images the threes
fives and eights for this example here
and so there's 28 rows and 28 columns
um and each pixel is a grayscale value
taking on values between 0 and 255
and what that means is that grayscale
value
basically
calculates how much of the ink is in
that little pixel
if it's zero there's nothing
and and then depending on the amount of
ink it goes can go all the way up to
255. i guess one of the reasons you
normalize is that the input features are
the pixels here right so we want somehow
a pixel in each image so each three
to mean the same thing doing the same
place relative to the three same place
exactly so if you had the images all
different sizes and shapes you know that
would be much harder to achieve but when
you see the convolutional neural network
coming up that'll it'll make that take
that even further right it'll yes it'll
be invariant to the the position of the
pixelness in essence
so along with this example there you
come with a class label which of course
are the digits 0 to 9.
so this is a
multi-class classification problem
you've got 10 classes
and the input features are these
28 by
28 which is
7
184 pixels per image you can think of
that just as a set of inputs per image
and we need to use the values in those
inputs to classify the the digits
so in this case we're going to build a
two layer feedforward neural network
which is just a more complicated version
of the one we showed you before
and it's going to have 256 units at the
first layer and 128 units at the second
layer and of course the output layer has
got 10 units
and if you count up all the parameters
there's
235
146 parameters all together and in this
community these are known as weights i
remember some of the first times we saw
these kinds of models we thought how can
we have four times as many parameters as
observations
exactly an overfit right so we're going
to talk quite a bit about how how we
avoid overfitting how in this these
kinds of models
i mean look at that 60 000 training
observations and 235 000 weights sounds
crazy yeah
so here's the network diagram
so there's the inputs so of course we've
got dot dots these are going up to you
know all the pixels in the image
so that's the input layer there's the
first hidden layer with 256 hidden units
and all these little arrows represent
all the weights going from
every input
to every hidden unit
and then likewise we have a second
hidden layer which takes as inputs the
values from the first hidden layer and
again
fully connected with weights going from
every
layer 1 unit to every layer two units
and then finally we have an output layer
which has got ten units represented in
the digits zero one through up to
through nine okay
and these actually estimate a
probability of being
each of the digits
and then those lead to a prediction in
this every historical comment this is
this is an example of a deep net i mean
it's got two hidden layers
in the in the 80s the original neural
networks typically had one hidden layer
and uh
tommy poggio from mit gave a talk at
stanford a few years ago
and he said in the 80s when the neural
nets came out with single hidden layers
some approximation theorems were proven
by mathematicians showing that if you
make the hidden layer l1 here have as
many an arbitrary number of hidden units
you can approximate any smooth function
well
so the conclusion from the community was
we only ever need one hidden layer
and in tommy's opinion that set the
field back by 30 years because people
just
they didn't bother with trying to with
uh with deep nets more than one layer
they just used one layer
and now this is not to criticize
mathematicians who are sure very clever
in their proofs but it just makes the
point that you shouldn't take
mathematics too seriously right and
sometimes it makes assumptions
and as we'll see later in this lecture
what's what's the uh
we're going to show you a network that's
got 50 layers right and there's a good
reason it works really well so we'll
talk a little bit more about the
function of these layers but the point
is with deep layer deep networks with
multiple layers you can really get much
better performance
okay let's talk a little bit about the
output layer
so
what we have is coming from the second
hidden so that we've had to introduce
some notation now because we've got
multiple layers
so we go from the second hidden layer to
the output layer and let's suppose
that computes some activation zm
then the output activation function
encodes what's known as the softmax
function this is the the same function
that's used in multi-class logistic
regression so it just takes these these
10 real numbers
and puts them through this nonlinear
transformation which turns them into
numbers between zero and one
that also sum to one
so this air is going from class zero up
to class nine
and and if you sum these quantities up
you'll get a probabilities that sum to
one
then also like in multi-class list
logistic regression we fit the model by
minimizing the negative multinomial log
likelihood
it's also known as cross-entropy in this
field
and here it is here it's just that
you've got your your training data with
two labels
and the two labels are are represented
by this the set of numbers y so y is a
is a vector of ten numbers and it'll be
one if the true clause for observation i
is m otherwise it'll be zero
and in this field it's that's known as
one hot encoded
what do we call that in statistics right
dummy variables dummy variables i think
their marketing department's definitely
better than ours
so if you think about this now if we've
summed from m going from zero to nine
but only one of these y's is one and so
that'll pick up the log of the
probability of the observed label right
and that's therefore the log likelihood
and we take the negative of the log
likely
so we're going to tell you about details
of fitting neural networks later but
let's look at the results on this data
set
so we show you two neural network
results and the one gets 2.3 percent
errors the other gets 1.8 percent errors
if you just fit a multinomial logistic
regression you get 7.2 percent errors
and if you fit linear discriminant
analysis which is another way of fitting
multi-class
classification models you get 12.7
percent errors so these are substantial
improvements over these pre-existing and
and more simple methods
and again
this problem with the digits
spelled one of the early successes for
neural networks in the 90s
so
we mentioned two forms of ridge
regularization which you know about
and dropout regularization which we will
tell you about a little bit later
and these both are essential and help
give this good performance
and again we'll give you some more
details of that later now we should
point out that this is a very overworked
problem these aren't the best rates
you're going to see you can find
reported rates that are less than 0.5
percent
misclassification error
for this particular data set this test
data set the human error rate is
reported at a around 0.2
or 10 20 of the 10 000 test images but
i think
so many people have tried and fit models
to this it could be a case that you know
we over training on the test set